okay tournament is about to start in
less than three minutes
uh anyone can join it's yeah it's free
for everyone
and there's there are prizes yeah
special things to
wrote to chess master for putting this
together
um it should be it should be a
yeah a very competitive field
oh ho means i in spanish i think
also okay good luck to my opponents um
ah what to play let's play london let's
stick with my main
fun repertoire um
i've been playing a lot of london
recently
so bishop d6
this is playable
i don't know if i've seen like this
exact move order
i'll play knight e5 like right away this
is a
follow-up plan too conflicted
f6
i'm already out of opening prep
this is very rare for me especially so
early bishop d6 was a new move
i'm sure it's been played before but
at least new for me
it's like i'm considering g4 it takes
take or
um takes takes with a the d-pawn
it probably doesn't work bishop e4 gets
murky
um so let's play this
yeah very very strange opening so far i
don't mind the position though
because black's committed to e6 and
there's ideas bishop d3 knight t2
maybe some idea of g4 as well
actually g4 could be a threat because
after this i take on e6
and queen e7 fair move
also has idea of queen b4 check
so let's play let's play knight c3
knight c3 might be threatening
the knight e5 would be so sweet if it
works
now there's g6 though
so maybe i can check first
provoke g6 and then just move back
and then the bishop will be a little bit
more stuck
and back to something else like if i
play this i might consider taking on d5
because after it takes takes takes 5
knight g7 winning the bishop
ah the problem is g6 still
yeah let's let's be a little bit careful
i'm gonna be solid too knight defends
the queen
the bishop attacks the bishop
oh it's probably close to just balanced
here
i want to use the c file uh rook c1
[Music]
now rook c1 knight b5 is one of the main
ideas
you can need two ideas as well
this is a position where the king is
just better in the center
to just support the pawns
no need to castle
also some idea knight knight a4
to c5 if black ever plays b6 and the
c6 is a bit more vulnerable
ooh that's interesting
i'll start with king d2
because c7 is hanging
so i'm happy with this trade
the idea is probably h4 at some point
so basically i'm trying to play on both
sides of the board
i target weaknesses on the queen side
and on the king side
it's very very positional now here
i'll take rook f1 and i'm finally
winning material
as e6 will fall and now this is a fork
this is nice this is a nice kind of
positional game
um good take on i'll just take on f8
and still target the c file now the five
is the main idea
okay i'll have to check that opening
that's a weird um
definitely a weird opening that i should
be prepared for
okay thanks for the game nazar cuttin
um i'll open the analysis board we'll go
back to tournament
so yeah some games still going i think
it should be possible to late join a few
rounds in
so if you're just joining the stream uh
you can use the join command
and play play this tournament it's ten
rounds of
three plus one so it should take
probably about 90 minutes
um i'll watch some of the games but
first things first let's quickly analyze
what was this opening bishop d6
oh this has been played at like top
level
what did kovsky play the the london og
very calm bishop g3 uh so it just plays
like a queen's gambit set up
i like what komski did i built kind of a
stone wall
engine is not too impressed check what
buzzy did
means magnus
yeah it looks like a solid position okay
let's watch some games um
oh yeah just click the link from
nightbot that's easier
uh the link is in the chat
i have to have to gauge the competition
so penguin won creep 31
let's check out this game oh it's i
barely know the rules
ooh this is interesting
it's a time scramble so
yeah time scrambles with a one second
increment are not easy
because really you have to play on pure
instincts
[Music]
i think white was worse earlier like
there was definitely potential for an
upset
but now white's probably better
oh i forgot to change the chat thing
oops
do do people should i leave the chat
thing on
let me ask the chat
no okay i'll get rid of the chat
uh there we go okay back to normal
i completely forgot about that
sorry chat sorry to the the 41
of you oh some people upset
maybe once in a while is that that's
actually pretty close
so once in a while i'll probably have it
on
maybe when i do like blindfold
because some some people oh let me go
back to
oops oh that was really close i almost
forfeited
oh that was really close yeah like
three more seconds i would have i would
have forfeited
and then i would have had to blame chat
oh f4 um i was showing this to a student
the other day
so there's a very specific move order to
play against the stone wall
which involves exactly this
i think it's just castling here
queen e1 is a main move
that's also possible
pretty sure bishop f5
yeah it's very important like in these
especially when white plays the swing
wall
to have the lightweight bishop outside
the pawn chain to trade it for white's
good bishop because then white's left
with a very bad bishop
and i really don't mind the structure um
because the f1 is not weak
could already consider knight e4
i think i'll start with rookie h most
flexible
and then eventually like eventually i
want to play this in f6
and queen b6 is a move i'll play queen
b6
just applying some some pressure there's
some x-ray vision against the king
there's a line takes takes and then i
just take everything on e5
so king h2 is very logical
um
[Music]
probably now knight e4
always have to be aware of this move i
don't think it really does much
and the main problem for white
when playing the stonewall is this
bishop
on uh on c1
which at least for the foreseeable
future it's not really going to have a
purpose in life
okay oh oh that's tricky
it's probably good for me but there's a
line to calculate f6 knight d7
queen d8 because i have to defend the
pawn
and then knight c5 um
probably bishop c5 bc5 queen d3
looks nice i'd be down the pawn but
just a really nice position
there's also a knight c4 here but we're
probably gonna get a situation where
it's like it's a knight versus a really
bad bishop
it could be a very good knight if i get
to d3
played chickened once before
so yeah those were the only two
candidate moves
oh this is actually a clever i guess it
allows this and
stuff happens so queen c7
yeah at this point it's very positional
i want to be
aware of time and not flag
and probably go for
realizing it's hard to get the knight to
d3
hmm
what to do
i could take
yeah the night wasn't doing anything
here because it was just like blocked by
the ponds
so i'm not sure i'm not sure what the
future is for the night
let's get the queen off the d file so
i'm hitting the b2 pawn
i want to go for rook d8
i'll start with rook t8
maybe rook ca queen a6
so hitting this pawn some idea of queen
e2
queen e2 rook d2
queen a4 tricky move
basically hitting the rook so white
can't take the pawn
and b3 i take a3
i want to double up
what i could do i'll consider it
is just shutting down the whole position
like c4 knight d5
queen b3 but then it might be hard to
break through
g4 oh
[Music]
okay let's actually shift let's shift
focus to the king side
you just have to play quick moves
knight d5 should come soon oh oh that
was a mouse slip
not a bad mouse slip though i had to
fight knight d5
okay let's go for this and rook d2
coming
rook d2 is still coming
[Music]
move this rook
and didn't see the breakthrough
oh that's a fork that's a nice fork
okay that's close
i was gonna say if this was hikaru's
chat there there'd be a lot of yup clock
only one yup clock in this chat
okay i've risen 300 rating points since
i started watching your stream oh
nice thanks for the awesome content
i'll take all the credits thank you
who is that that was drewskis
yeah keep it up and thanks for subbing
for five months
you like my shirt oh the jacket this is
it's technically a jacket yeah hikaru
was funny we interviewed hikaru on
stream today
and he was wearing the same the same
jacket
it's um yeah it's a st louis rapid and
blitz
uh what year was it i don't think it
says the year
maybe 20 2018 or 2019.
um i can see if they're still selling it
it would be cubotique parallel
hmm
i'm not seeing it
oh they have they have a very similar
one
huboutique if you google cue boutique st
louis
uh i think this is a similar one this is
the world chats hall of fame jacket
anyway um
opponent almost didn't show up but it's
here
okay so this is this is a title player
playing taco fall i'm gonna play london
so this is the thing about swiss
pairings is like as you keep winning
opponents will keep getting more
difficult because i'm playing someone
who also
won their first two games okay this is
one way of playing
um go for this line early bishop h6
black is not afraid
i usually play a position like this
without the knight committed to f3
i i more often play this position with
castling
but this still looks enjoyable
yeah c5 is a move
hmm
c5 is a good move
i'm wondering if i can castle here and
then
takes and we could just get in like a
dragon structure
with a knight misplaced on d7 i think
i'll do that
because if takes takes we basically have
a sicilian dragon
resembling some yugoslav
where like more often than that comes to
c6
i haven't committed to bishop c4 yet
which is probably good
so let's just go for the attack
going for h5
yeah there's a nifty idea let's imagine
v5 h5 knight takes h5
i would have rook h5 gh5 queen g5
wouldn't
just force me
this is a classic very classic attack
against
the kingside fianchetto
because the combination of pawn bishop
oh
are we going into it oh
i probably should not have allowed that
but now i have to live with the
consequences i could take
i could take taken in queen h6 but then
knight g4
it's getting weird
i've kind of committed myself
because knight okay there's also knight
d5
95 might be the way to go
g594 queen e3
and then there's takes takes
takes takes i think that's good
it's gonna yeah it's getting very wild
so i sacked upon but the knights kind of
hanging there's still attack
on the king side um
i'm very willing to sack a rook
or two rooks
assuming i'm just mating
and then that in d5 is actually very
useful because
in some cases i hit e7 like if knight f6
oh wait is this just winning
so knight takes e7
i should start with 97.
it's very close to winning
why considering this
there's a really cool line
um i think i want to play it
i can start by taking and there's takes
king here
here
uh does it work is queen e7
queen e7 might defend for black
let's take here first because there's 96
possibilities
[Music]
i'm looking for force mates
okay i can win the queen where's my mate
though
okay winning the queen is good enough
yeah this is completely winning i'm
pretty sure i missed some kind of horse
mates
um what do i want to do here this is
horse mates
and then queen f7 okay that was a nice
game that was a nice kind of
attacking game um yeah i
basically got everything i wanted
i spent a lot of time almost flagged
but uh there's a really cool line
open analysis board there's a cool line
um i spent a lot of time here because i
wanted to take and then queen h6 like
sac the queen
and it's very close to working
it might actually work because if takes
takes king here
uh knight f5 this is mating this would
be a really sweet mate
i just didn't fully calculate this move
uh because after knight f5 there's king
g5
it seems really close
but even like looking at this position
i'm not seeing it
i could take bishop e2 f4
i think white's going to run out of fuel
here it takes you could stack everything
and it might be made
but it might not be so let's check with
the engine
so first of all is white winning here
wow engine is so cold-blooded
this is minus minus 5.7
so let's go back so this position is
winning
uh what did i play oh yeah i took on
yeah like this is uh
oh so stockfish not finding force mate
yeah i thought there could be something
like with meta five but this is simple
enough
okay that was nice
this is a quick game too um oh penguin
also
three out of three
i could very possibly be playing penguin
very soon
i should check my game with penguin
he beat me in this uh this arena
this game i think it was this game
yeah you played this knight c3 move
so if i run into this i'll play
because e6 i played i played knight c6
and this is losing
probably just a6 it takes
okay queen a5 looks simple
bishop g4 also maybe i'll play bishop g4
play this line
oh next round starts in 10 seconds okay
let's focus closing tabs
okay oh i'm playing full down
good luck pull down i've played pool dan
many times full-time beat me the last
time we played
every time i play full dance we play
like some crazy opening
oh it's it's going to be crazy again i
guess
usually a3 is intending b4
but now b4 is not possible so
it's basically a dragon with white
committing to a3
interesting
i guess the queen
queen can find a home here bishop d2
probably queen v6
now hitting b2
keep developing
i think d6 is very logical yeah kind of
one of these uh
these dragon positions the center is
stronger than usual i might want to play
vision a6
dance around with the queen
at some point the queen might swing over
looking at bishop g4
yeah maybe bishop g4 is the way to go
try and provoke f3
and then bishop e6
not sure if i'm achieving so much
i am allowing my d5 here probably have
to play queen d8
between c5 there's there's bishop e3
it could be trading or not
i want to keep my bishop
yeah it's kind of a game of cat and
mouse like this knight
not sure if the knight is happy on f4
because it's kind of restricted by pawns
but they work on b8
so there's a clear target for the work
in the bishop
potential ideas of queen b6
i should really be considering e5
e5 looks really nice
because knight h3 now i can take a
knight h5 and this square is so juicy
queen h4 coming
e5 it's a type of move that is very
rarely good in the dragon
but yeah here it was was justified
hitting h3 white's probably debating
between these moves
still takes work
like i don't really want to play knight
f4
even though it's probably not a bad move
there's f5 which is it's very ambitious
oh what to do
i'm gonna play this first because i
might wanna play f5 the king is just
better
on on h8 anyway
if queen g4 i'd probably
probably avoid the queen trade maybe the
queen just goes all the way back
i mean overall i like the position queen
d8
so now f5 is actually prevented
how to continue
the queen found a new home rook is
pinned king is tied down to the rook
this rook is stuck defending the pawn
there's no bishop e3
some idea of eventually using the bishop
interesting
hmm
i mean i'm playing a5 to prevent b4 or
at least discourage b4
key e2 delayed bond cloud
really like to make a 5 work
let's start with a4
i got to be very cognizant of time
i'm probably going for d5 next
because the king's in the center
and if if it takes i have f5 first and
then takes back and i'll have a nice
wall of center pawns
but actually if takes here takes
i probably just want to take back and
then then play f5
okay time is ticking
bishop d2 safe move
hmm like we need seven
okay time scramble time
oh i think f4 is a panic move
let's take first and then f5 coming
okay that took work good fights
i mean i thought it was gonna be easier
after i took on h3
but maybe not quite
okay um
yeah i was close back to tournaments
so four out of four penguin is also four
out of four
what
alexa wanted to chime in there
anyway um what oh no no no no alexa
quiet
no no no alexa quiet
wait did you really huh
okay um
oh games are still going so penguin
keeps winning i could very well
so there's eight there's eight people
with perfect scores
you could very well play penguin soon
oh also i barely know the rules
okay
man it's turning into a long stream but
it's fun
um this is probably the last round to
late join
i think if it's not too late already
yeah i was going to use opening tree
from penguin but it's really
i've played penguin so many times but
i've no
pretty much his whole repertoire at
least against my openings
so really the only thing i wanted to
check was what i already checked
in this was kind of a jobavo london
so there's 10 rounds total we are almost
halfway through
i guess we can watch the final game
here so
rook ending hey it's anonymous
it's anonymous gifting a sub to lunar
eclipse
so i saw i saw an eclipse once
you guys want to see an eclipse photo
this game could take
a while you go to flickr
alexa what's the difference between a
lunar eclipse and a solar eclipse
a solar eclipse is when the moon aligns
between the sun and the earth
blocking the sun's light and causing
total or semi darkness in the daytime on
the earth's surface
a lunar eclipse is when the earth aligns
between the sun and the moon
casting the earth's shadow on the moon
causing it to turn a dark red during the
night time interesting
lunar eclipses occur every few months
but solar eclipses are about a year and
a half apart
so this was um so two years ago 2017
um there is like this big rage about the
the solar eclipse and
uh st louis was like on the path of
totality
actually just outside st louis so i went
to like this uh this kind of nature park
and took photos um it lasted
lasted close to two minutes
and yeah to look at the at least for
like
this shot this was a nice shot because
the cloud was acting as a filter
um but to look at the partial eclipse
you needed special glasses
i didn't really have i just had like my
my camera and the zoom lens
um but there were a lot of people like
in this nature park
like very advanced photography equipment
this game is still going oh they're
playing out group versus rook
i'd rather revisit eclipse photos
oh yeah this one this was with a wide
angle lens
um i had i actually had a couple cameras
i had i had a drone too i have to find
the drone footage from that day
oh yeah then this like when there's an
eclipse the shadows are not
like they're they're in the crescent
shape if you look closely at the shadows
they're like they're
kind of a different shape than in
typical shadows
anyway
how did that start oh that started from
anonymous gifting a subtle lunar eclipse
100 wow so many moves what
oh ouch who did that
why did that ouch that was probably a
mouse slip
that's so tragic but so hilarious
is this going to be 200 moves no boxing
i made before then that's a long game
though
wow what a sad finish
what a very sad finish
okay next round starting
okay king boris good luck
let's play stick with the main i mean
repertoire
now this is my kind of this new london
idea
um i don't know much beyond this
uh but it's an interesting position
i think g4 so g4 is a very typical idea
here
a simple idea just pawn swarming
and yeah with d5 now the bishop's plot
so i'm not scared about my queen
i could play this right away
i think i'll play 92 first just support
my bishop
and it's a situation where
it looks very dangerous for galactic
castle kingside
because i'm in very good shape to attack
so black might end up casting
sign but i'm still ready to push
actually queen d7 g5 then i would have
to go back to g8
there's some knight b5 potential
that's logical that move enables this
because uh
bishop supports
let's just keep pushing i have knight e4
i'm
probably okay with trading queen g3
i'm kind of discouraging knight g6
because h5 will be in the air
yeah this queen of three line
i think it was like a lila innovation
but stockfish also approves it it's a
move that
i think has become more known
recently
okay this is still going to be a fight
so this pawn is kind of overextended but
it's defended
really not easy to exploit
black going for trades
so h5 is actually very tempting here
i think we'll play knight h5
the black has to make some concession to
defend the pawn like either this this
or castling
castling is probably the best move
now the question is
what to do i really want to play h5 but
my knight's in the way
i think he's just king b1 like what else
to do
and see what black does
bishop g2 actually bishop g2 f4 is an
idea
yeah and i'll connect the rooks so then
king b1 the rook's not
undefended so c5 won't be
playable uh
queen d5 may be expected but thinking b1
it's going to be sharp
really a matter of who can attack who
more quickly
f5 wow
f5 is playable
kind of like f4 here
or maybe f3 even
i'll play f3
i realize f4 like just kind of closes
things down i want to open things up
okay with the trade like takes takes
yeah we trade everything
oh i don't really want to trade queens
but i probably have to
[Music]
hmm
so g5 might not be better here
if i take i probably want to play g5
i could be slightly worse here actually
depending what black does
it's still unclear
okay that move makes me really happy f4
was like the
the key idea for black
i was probably in trouble after f4
[Music]
i guess i'll play h5 why not
that's a good move
[Music]
oh that's actually a really good move
playbook h3
first
b3 oh
getting forked
now it's just a matter of playing
quickly
hmm
i'm down upon some fight
interesting
definitely some fights
play c4
here we go a meeting attack
is real again threading meat
turning meat there we go okay
man that's close that's probably worse
somehow some way uh
back to tournament okay
yeah opponents played well um
i got low on time uh
yeah this maneuver is very typical like
the knight
loves to come to e4 and like i couldn't
really stop it
and like when it comes to e4 it attacks
this this and this
so like i'm already in some danger here
did not
play the right move probably had to play
rook
g1 here and then
when i was down the pawn but one upon
back
and rookie five kind of saved me i
thought black
should black should take and
take probably the best approach
but anything could have happened
anyway why do i have the most points
oh because math there's some kind of
tiebreaker system
i think
the penguin yeah i mean i'm gonna
be playing a very strong player next
round
um
curious maybe there's someone else that
can join
we played normal one
yeah i played down the finest
wasn't our first game that was like the
crab i think
have i ever been to norway
i've never been to norway i wanted to go
there was a chess event scheduled for
may
the chess party in norway but it kind of
got
cancelled or postponed but uh
it's a country that's high on my my
bucket list
i've been to iceland which is probably
the closest i've been to norway
whoa
i think bishop d5 should still be oh
bishop d5 there's this move
wow yeah
these endings could be tricky
okay playing green arrow
who is this this is someone i know this
person
oh jovava london time
or whatever this is
yeah i played against this before i
think b5 is a move here
and then just develop try and develop
normally
some idea of h6 knight h5
also ideas of knight b6 to c4
that's really the only only idea with
this knight
um unless i maybe have e5 too
not sure
sorry with this let's be safe let's be
solid
thanks for subbing rookie mistakes
welcome back something for 11 months
the e5 is actually looking attractive
knight b6 is just b3 and hit me
hit me 645. solving with prime
thanks for that e3
okay i'm just going to play a quick
simple move
rookie will be useful assuming the e5
break comes
in general you want to put your books on
files
which are most likely to open if there's
no open files in the position already
so this is actually really interesting
it's kind of a pawn sacrifice
but maybe it's worth it
let's just do it because b5 might fall
on the end
but the center is opening up
this is the type of move like if it was
a longer game
i'd have to calculate but here it's just
pure intuition
a lot of choices for white oh
doesn't take anything so first move that
comes to mind is b4
let's do it bishop on b4 would be very
nice
center is defended the knight's now
pinned but so is this knight
and queen a5 is an idea
probably have to take back unless i can
throw in queen a5
queen a5 might be a really nice
inclusion
so i'm threatening queen a1 knight b1
and i win the queen
and the main idea i'm unpainting my
knight so king b1 i can take with the
knight
leaving the bishop is a a less
purposeful
piece and i exert more pressure here
rook b8 is probably the move i want to
play now
i can i can also take on there's so many
options here
you can take an e5 with a rook maybe
threatening this
the rook b1 looks
looks difficult for white to deal with
because normally the king wants to hide
in the corner but that's not possible
this pin combined with the potential pin
on the b file
i'm looking for a move for white i'm not
seeing anything
which is probably a good sign because
the simple thread is just
take okay this is probably desperation
oh there's queen d3
i wonder if i can be cheesy
and just play king h8
would be the ultimate cheese it's risky
but let's do it because i just don't
allow queen d3
because uh i think this is just more
powerful i mean this was probably
objectively good
but i'm more interested in winning the
night amendment meeting
eventually
so okay i should calculate like queen d3
but then just takes
takes takes and then there's no b3
i guess there's queen d3 takes king c1
okay okay here i'm winning the queen
anything better
let's win the queen
bishop is still attacked and so is a
knight
i'll take the knight
a pawn is hanging too
okay this is pleasant
what to do i'm enjoying this position
too much
take this thing and then oh my brook is
hanging
play this move i need to take and take
and bishop five coming
this is also an idea
d3 it's nice being up a queen
yeah i'm i'm happy with that game it was
kind of a confusing
middle game position uh but this kind of
paid off
and so i was more expecting
okay 35 games still going so that was
quick as mark spending takes
and then i eventually lose this pawn i
was probably going to take the knight
i don't think i would have i don't know
maybe i would have considered this
um yeah this is actually a nice
in-between move
i was mainly looking at this takes
um and then taking the queen
i mean there's so many branches to this
line
the casting queen side was a really
risky move
because the attack came like very very
quickly
okay so i feel like i'm in good form
i've had some smoothie games i feel like
watching
so watching like this uh these carlson
and hikaru games
it definitely helps put me in better
form oh penguin's still playing
hey i finished before penguin
oh it's a time scramble oh
penguin in some trouble
but penguin's like very tricky in these
situations
and very fast oh wait i
i miscounted penguin penguins down or up
a bishop
i just saw black's attack
yeah penguin's gonna win
hey it's crosby 87 goat
gifting a sub to zodlack okay so i'm
definitely playing penguin next
i'll probably be
i'll probably be white what does penguin
play
penguin what does penguin play
he plays like french i think
i should i should really check his yeah
what is he playing
uh games i'm pretty much guaranteed to
play him
with white oh so he plays e4 e5
so it's a question he also plays french
let's see this chew likes french oh
i played them in the slime before
so maybe i'll play
i don't know i'll figure it out
i'll play e4
so he plays e5 do i play nagminson
i play spanish i don't want a spanish
repertoire though
let's play spanish i think he plays i
assume he plays mainline
i could be wrong though oh he plays this
stuff
oh let's play
some vague memory of this line
i think it's d4 there's some cool idea
it takes knight d5
oh does this not work
this probably doesn't work at all
oh d4 is a terrible move oh
you played that against 97.
okay this is completely butchered
opening crap
yeah the whole idea was 95 bishop g5
ah okay i've just down the pawn i'm just
down upon i got confused this is bad
opening preparation
but maybe i can win a pond back
accidental gambit
yeah i guess i was more looking at pawn
takes knight d5
immediately with the knights on c6 but
at least he's thinking
he's probably just confused might be
watching the stream
i don't think he's streaming shout out
to penguin
people should follow him on on twitch
very strong player
play c6 i'm tempted to sack a bishop and
then get a knight to d6
probably doesn't work though
so yeah there's there's a few ways to
defend the pawn
they all have their drawbacks though
there's always c3 like
yeah maybe this isn't so bad like the
more he's thinking the more confidence
i'm getting
uh i can take here
bishop b oh pawn b5 wow
that's very sneaky oh so he wants to
play c5
i can play c4 here
this reminds me of go and it's like the
cutting points
it's confusing
anyway i want a pawn back so it's equal
material
bishop a4 doesn't work
my pawn's still in danger though
knight f4
[Music]
probably not f4 mcqueen e7
actually queen e7 queen e2 i take with
king
promise bishop b7 is coming
and have to deal with it i guess queen
yeah there should be seven queen b3 rook
b8
maybe b4 here
i i can't i can't sit not doing anything
so the idea is takes in bishop b2 and
then this pawn is weak
if i can win this pawn it's easier to
defend this pawn
interesting you can take
languages bishop b2 coming
so there's a line here here uh queen g6
i take on d4
oh but takes hits the bishop
oh does that work
i can play this move
i'm holding on to both pawns now i don't
care about my rook
your bishop's more valuable than my rook
and this pawn should be much more of a
weakness
yeah so it's kind of an exchange sack
oh that's tricky
maybe f3 no that's really tricky
maybe f
to do here queen c2
ah i don't know what to do just take
that
oh that doesn't work though
there's a panic move
wow i want a time oh that was a very
slow time scramble
man oh man
it's so it's so hard with the increments
i never thought i would flag penguin
with increments
because usually penguins unflaggable
without
all you do oh thank you she you nine
shoe9 i appreciate that and hello to
finney finney
okay yeah that game will deserve further
analysis
in the future but
i just have to like mentally regroup
honestly i i don't think that was a
great quality game i had i messed up the
opening
but somehow somehow is interesting
actually let me check
i'm just curious if i stumbled into like
some known thing
oh thanks for that yeah thanks g cook
the 1000 bits
and things down dd the smash bits
yeah d4 is is not a move even though
okay it's been played
by lower level masters
i got confused because i had a game once
with knight e7
where this position and d4 is uh is
really interesting
um and the bishop's not yet committed
and after it takes knight d5
it's a really cool line and black's not
careful there's mating ideas
but uh i really just got confused
anyway yeah i don't want to like
accidentally forfeit the game
by being in a different tab
so games are wrapping up um
whoa it's a hundred dollars thanks for
the great content thanks so much
uh i really appreciate that i'm glad
you're enjoying it
thanks so much okay playing ricky rich
okay i have to focus spanish penguin to
the arctic
oh that's where penguins live
can you banish someone to their natural
habitat
i saw penguins in australia
c3 is a tricky move
gg oh thanks
um i'm debating
what line to to play here because if i
if i play this there's
there's takes and i'm not sure let's go
for it
um okay that's what i was hoping for now
i'm back in my main prop
queen b3 c4 is the main line
um i think knight a3 is a playable move
queen c1 also playable
play bishop f5 yeah the drawback of
queen c1 is like i just have nice
development
i might want to play h6 before e6 the
event of knight h4
and then rook
rook c1 will come eventually ruxiates to
align with the queen
i'm curious if probably don't want to
allow knight h4
so i'll play h6
yeah it's kind of like a reverse queen's
gambit
or i've the one i've been the one like
pushing the c pawn
white has a semi-slav kind of triangle
setup
i probably just want a complete
development
at some point it's probably going to
take
i always have to be careful of this move
but yeah the general plan put the rooks
in the center
be solid rook c8 will maybe threaten to
take
twice on on d4 because of the pin
hmm
yeah we might end up trading probably
take with pawn
that way i can take and play c5 again
i should still consider this move too
except not anymore
okay so now there's no more knight d7
bishop d3 good move
yeah very much positional game
so maybe what i can do we can just trade
and then get in c5
hey look it's hail krishnan oh hey
hail how's it going i
take bishop takes
yeah white has some annoying control
here
not thrilled with this position actually
put the queen back on c7 maybe some idea
knight d7 bishop f6
because white has very good control over
e5
there's a funny line so i'm going to
allow this
oh forgot f4 i was thinking bishop g5
i'm kind of gambling upon
okay f4 right away is less scary
bishop c5 here
okay with trades
that's a terrifying move
i could play f5
i probably will end up playing f5 unless
oh f6 is
f6 takes knight e4 oh that's so nifty
yeah knight e4 is nice because the queen
defends g7
i'll watch out for time again
if the light gets to e4 then i'll be
very happy the bishop won't be so
so menacing with the pawn here
if if white takes
oh that's a tricky move
let's start with this defend everything
still want to play this
take with queen and then probably double
up
these pawns will be targets
here's an acrostic during your time
pressure
e4 are you single and discreet lust for
the streamers
i think i just want to double up
so c4 could come but then d4 e5
ge5 might be in the main plan anyway
oh that's a good move
let's play d4 and then take and
hopefully win back upon
simplifying a little bit
objectively it's very close to equal
this is what i was hoping for because
now the king just gets to
the square rook defends everything
hmm
it's all about the furthest pushed past
pawn
um
oh no i'm losing
oh that's so sad
ah oh so close
queening would have been stalemate oh
it's so sad i i had the stalemate trap
set up well played ricky rich
well played um there there were
opportunities for a draw there
uh i kind of over pushed a lot yeah h5
was a bad move
um if i wanted to play for a win i don't
know what i should have done
anyway life goes on um
i'm probably still tied for first i
don't know though
what round is this i even know they're
round
oh i'm still okay i still said i'm in
first place
so that's nice
so maybe still controlling my own
destiny
okay playing this line against the
modern
going for the early e5
i think e5 can be played right away
and then as far as i know it's useful to
include
h3 to
then castle and now i don't have to
worry about bishop g4
and there's some idea eventually bishop
a6
interesting
so if i play a4 bishop a6 is kind of
annoying
but maybe not too annoying
like worst case i have c4
i just want to play rook team one
[Music]
so maybe bishop c4
also thanks for subbing
to do you said a4
[Music]
bishop a4 c4
let's go for this
oh as we're expecting bishop a6 there
okay so these are like rook d1 and c4
are the moves i want to get in
um play c4 right away bishop a6 is
probably playable
reminiscent of like a scotch opening
it might be six expected
yeah i think i'm okay giving away this
bishop
it wasn't doing too much anyway
and there's a lot of potential there's
gonna say to attack
knight g7 is a good move
ooh it may have gone wrong
i have this move hitting the rook and
preparing bishop
d6
it could get very crazy c6 is also
hanging
okay bishop d6 is nice
yeah c6 falls
this is very nice and then like c3
um a5 is also hanging
yeah earlier i was going to say there's
potential to like attack on the king
side
but the queen needs to to stay defending
the bishop
f5
wow does f5 work
wow i might be in trouble here
that was very resourceful
now i'm actually oh no i have this move
takes takes takes
i think this saves me i'd better save me
so this is associated
but this is a counter exhibition zig in
between move
okay now queen h4
i still have this nice construction
this is like the most solid man-made
structure
i don't think i care too much about
takes takes
maybe i do
i guess i kind of do
i mean white's in pretty good control
here
you just have to keep everything
defended
and knight might come to d6
because rook wants to be improved
again the clock very stress inducing
probably rook d3 i always have to watch
out for like these weird tactics with e5
but rook d3 and rook bd1
looks like a simple plan
maybe keem g2 for good measure
interesting h5
idea king g2 and then rook h1
okay i was i think that was a clean game
there's some complicated moments
but got the job done um
so that was around i was around nine
so one more round left
you haven't screamed in a while i missed
the informative chess
i stream i've been streaming almost
every day but maybe
i haven't streamed recently this time
also welcome back reps wraps for jesus
thanks for stopping for two months yeah
i streamed
i streamed three times yesterday and
this is my second
stream of today um
have i been flat i guess i have been
flagging a lot of people
this one second increment is very
deceiving
because you get too comfortable and then
in yeah when you're less than like five
seconds it's so easy to flag
i guess i haven't done one of these
tournaments like play the full
tournament
like this oh penguin pod oh penguin
oh penguin lost to ricky rich ooh
yeah ricky rich is is very should maybe
be renamed tricky rich
now i kind of regret not taking the draw
because that could ultimately affect the
outcome of things so i'm going to play
one of these people
comsack or oh was comsack the one
oh it's probably the one who won that
rook ending
i mean maybe that was a different game
okay final round
starts in five seconds
giango okay i'll stick with my main
rapper tour
i'm just gonna try and play good moves
do i know this person
from canada
jing's number one fan interesting
generally i enjoy this move order
of course it depends what black does but
yeah
so knight a3 is a nice uh nice idea
um preparing knight c4 and also
the idea semi queen b2 with
wait a minute i had this earlier or i
had this other day and i messed it up
i think knight b5 is a move here
yeah knight b5 and then eventually queen
takes d4
some tricky variation
yeah this is actually a really tricky
variation
takes takes
um and something i should really just
know
but no one ever plays this
let's take with queen
so is a is a question if takes do i go
for knight c7
probably not it just looks way too risky
and it's probably
it leads to an easy position for black
to play so i probably just take
and then make black decide how to defend
knight c7
currently i'm threading 96
which opponent induces
has to take
yeah a6 was a pleasant surprise
thanks for subbing eric eric kim
for for five months so i have the bishop
here
i think i want to play c3
just extra solid this bishop is not
going anywhere for the time being
if it takes
i might take off with the c pawn
just to get the c file f6 is very
logical
develop a bishop so if knight b6 vision
b3 the knight blocks the pawn
that's hard to develop also anticipating
this move
the ship should be nice on c4 some
future idea f4 f5
interesting let's take towards the
[Music]
center
there might be a decision coming up if i
should take the knight
which i probably shouldn't should
probably just keep the bishop here
okay it wants to play another f5 so
let's play e4
very likely see this well i can actually
get some initiative here
yeah a lot of moves coming with threats
that's a question do i castle
at a5 coming castling or rook d1 or def
d5 looks nice d5 knight d4
oh yeah box fighting also this move
might be the move to go for
i'm just trying to keep my bishop here
and consolidate
king probably wants to it depends what
black does
because 95
and this knight is very devious
hmm
might end up stacking up on
like a4 here
even some like king e2
d6 is coming
and go for b3
trying to calculate a long line with
knight g2
[Music]
liking d2
yeah this is probably just equal i have
to watch my clock
yeah i mean that can get the obstacle
bishop ending which i was trying to
avoid
and there's still life in that position
avoiding v6
[Music]
um
this could be a long game
playing for a win
oops
okay easy one
okay got the job done
oh so the um yeah i kind of panicked in
this time scramble and
almost accidentally pre-moved lost
but um
so the the move i'm most proud of this
game
was d5 d5 just came at the exactly right
moment
because otherwise the king would walk to
d5 and i could be worse
um but then yeah once these pawns start
rolling
and start rolling it's uh it's not easy
to stop
anyway hey clear first
nice finish person like oh
thank you yeah i mean this this one
second increments
i was probably very close to flagging on
multiple occasions
well it was a fun tournament i honestly
was not expecting to win it
given like this um
yeah very strong player creep 30
who's also a streamer
and penguin kumian
and uh
and maybe some other yeah this magnet
is is also very strong anyway that was
fun
i'll probably put the whole thing on
youtube
uh so if you're watching in the future
on youtube thanks for watching
uh thanks again to to wrote to chess
master for
for organizing this recently picked up
the london because you made it look like
so much
fun i'm on a 13 win
streak 23 24 games won and got to 1k
elo thanks for the great content
that's great first by the way thanks so
much
and thank you quirkback for subbing